passer d'une question un peu spécial que
vous me demandez là j'ai des difficultés
à répondre oui je suis prête à venir en
aide aux parents orphelins
personnellement vous seriez prête à
faire quoi pour pour ces gens là avant
d'orphelins ça dépend ce qui m'est
proposé en fin juillet ce qui m'a
suggéré
il faut agir intelligemment sortie en
boîte à des sorties en boîte
on va l'avoir
sortie en boîte
les sorties en boîte pourquoi pas
voyez-vous pour eux et aux parents aux
parents d'orphelins mais ces décisions
feu là ils n'ont pas de parents c'est
idiot votre question on attend quoi pour
aider les parents d'orphelins à sortir
du trou à votre avis à l'heure actuelle
je crois que c'est notre gouvernement
qui dépense beaucoup d'argent où il ne
faudrait pas qu'il faudrait de le
dépenser sur ces choses là et non
lorsqu'il fait alors monsieur seriez
vous prêt à venir en aide aux parents
d'orphelins oui parce que je trouve
qu'ils ont besoin de décors préhension
connaissez vous même des parents
orphelins mais beaucoup ont cours
actuellement
là vous vous posez des choses ce sont
des gens qui sont un peu comme vous au
bout du rouleau et j'en ai encore des
maîtres à faire beaucoup l'eau je suis
pas au bout du rouleau pense que c'est
difficile pour un orphelin de garder un
contact accès par an soit assez dur quoi
seriez vous prête à venir en aide aux
parents d'orphelins aux parents de
refaire oui oui oui vous feriez quoi
pour les aider à sortir du trou ça va ce
par la télé ça un ancien la radio pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux